>>> ONE IN EIGHT PEOPLE WHO
BATTLED COVID WILL DEVELOP LONG
COVID WITH SYMPTOMS PERSISTING
AS LONG AS TWO YEARS AFTER FIRST
BECOMING SICK.
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT ESTIMATES
THERE MAY BE AS MANY AS 23
MILLION LONG COVID PATIENTS IN
THE U.S. ALONE.
SOME OF THE MOST COMMON SYMPTOMS
INCLUDE PAIN AND DIFFICULTY
BREATHING AND MANY PATIENTS ALSO
REPORT COGNITIVE PROBLEMS, BUT
NOW THERE IS AN EXPERIMENTAL
TREATMENT TO TARGET BRAIN FOG.
CHIEF MEDICAL CORRESPONDENT DR.
SANJAY GUPTA REPORTS.
>> I'M ON HOME OXYGEN FOR 500
DAYS.
>> WOW.
>> I HAD PHYSICAL THERAPY, A
NURSE WHO CAME EVERY DAY.
>> WAS THERE A POINT WHEN YOU
SAID, OKAY, THESE SYMPTOMS ARE
NOT GOING AWAY?
>> YES, FOUR WEEKS AFTER I LEFT
THE HOSPITAL I COULDN'T
UNDERSTAND WHY I STILL FELT SO
BAD, WHY EVERYTHING HURT.
I WAS ON A WALKER.
I WAS CRYING.
MY PCP SAID, BARBARA, YOU HAVE
LONG COVID.
>> Reporter: THAT WAS SEPTEMBER
2020.
BARBARA'S LIFE WAS TURNED UPSIDE
DOWN.
14 YEARS AS A RETAIL MANAGER,
LEADING AND COACHING A STAFF OF
MORE THAN 20, WAS NO MORE.
NOW EXCHANGED FOR A LIFE OF
ALARMS, REMINDERS, AND PILLS.
>> I HAVE THIS LIST.
ALARMS, THAT IS FOR THINGS THAT
I NEED TO DO DAILY.
>> Reporter: IN THE YEARS TO
COME THERE WILL BE TEXTBOOKS
WRITTEN ABOUT LONG COVID, BUT
WHAT IS INCREASINGLY CLEAR NOW
IS THAT FOR TOO MANY PEOPLE THE
SYMPTOMS COME AND THEN THEY
STAY, PERSISTING FOR WEEKS,
MONTHS AND FOR BARBARA EVEN
YEARS.
>> I FEEL LIKE THERE IS A VIRUS
IN MY BRAIN AND IT'S CHANGING
THINGS IN MY BRAIN BECAUSE I
CAN'T THINK, I CAN'T REMEMBER.
>> ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS THAT
I NOTICED WAS THAT PEOPLE WERE
COMPLAINING OF REALLY STRIKING
COGNITIVE PROBLEMS.
>> Reporter: OFTEN CALLED BRAIN
FOG, HOWEVER, THAT IS ALLUSIVE,
HARD TO DEFINE, BUT AS
PSYCHOLOGIST JAMES JACKSON
STARTED TO SEE MORE OF THESE
PATIENTS, HE ALSO SAW SOMETHING
MORE SPECIFIC.
SOMETHING SO-CALLED BRAIN FOG
PATIENTS SEEM TO SHARE IN
COMMON, THEY HAD LOST THE
ABILITY TO ATTEND, TO SIMPLY PAY
ATTENTION.
>> WITH OTHER CHRONIC ILLNESSES
THE COGNITIVE DEFICITS WE SEE
SEEM TO FOCUS ON ATTENTIONAL
PROBLEMS, PROBLEMS WITH
PROCESSING SPEED.
OFTEN MEMORY COMPLAINTS, BUT
WHEN YOU DIG DOWN YOU FIND THAT
REALLY THE PROBLEM IS ATTENTION.
YOU KNOW, THEY'RE NOT ATTENDING
AND FUNCTIONALLY THEY
EXPERIENCED THAT AS A DEFICIT IN
MEMORY.
>> Reporter: BUT WITH THAT IN
MIND, HE DECIDED TO TRY OUT A
TREATMENT FOR LONG COVID THAT
MIGHT SURPRISE YOU, A VIDEO
GAME.
>> JUST LIKE PRACTICING SPORTS
OR MUSIC, A TOUGH CHALLENGE WILL
HELP YOU IMPROVE.
I THINK I'M DOING PRETTY GOOD.
>> AS YOU DO BETTER IT GETS
HARDER, AS YOU DO WORSE IT GETS
EASIER, IT'S VERY DYNAMIC.
>> Reporter: THERE IS EVEN A
DOSE THAT THEY PRESCRIBE IN THE
TRIAL.
25 MINUTES A DAY, FIVE DAYS A
WEEK, EIGHT WEEKS.
>> IS IT GOING TO TRANSLATE INTO
YOU BEING ABLE TO DO YOUR TAXES?
ARE YOU GOING TO BE ABLE TO BE
ORGANIZE?
DRIVING?
AND WHEN YOU STOP THE GAME DO
ALL THOSE BENEFITS STOP?
AND THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
I THINK THE LITERATURE AND THE
SCIENCE THAT HAS EMERGED IS YOU
DON'T NEED TO BE PLAYING THE
GAME FOR THE REST OF YOUR LIFE
TO ACCRUE THE BENEFIT, BUT THAT
IS CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT
CRITICS HAVE RAISED.
>> Reporter: THE QUESTION IS CAN
IT HELP HEAL THE CHANGES
SOMETIMES SEEN IN THE BRAINS OF
LONG COVID PATIENTS LIKE THIS?
LOSS OF GRAY MATTER IN THE
FRONTAL CORTEX, TISSUE DAMAGE
OVER HERE AND AN OVERALL
SHRINKING OF THE BRAIN.
NONE OF THIS IS EASY AND TO BE
SURE A VIDEO GAME WON'T BE A
PANACEA FOR BARBARA, BUT AT THIS
POINT ANYTHING SEEMS TO HELP.
>> HOW DID IT HELP YOU?
>> ATTENTION TO DETAIL, PAYING
ATTENTION, FOCUSING, SOME
MEMORY.
>> HOW ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT
THE FUTURE?
ARE YOU OPTIMISTIC?
>> I TAKE IT DAY BY DAY RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE IF YOU TRY TO TAKE
IT MONTH BY MONTH IT'S REALLY
HARD TO TRY TO THINK THAT FAR
OUT.
>> IT'S ALMOST LIKE RETRAINING
THE BRAIN AFTER HAVING A STROKE,
YOU KNOW, TRYING TO GET THINGS
BACK ON TRACK, AND IT'S SO
IMPORTANT WHEN YOU HAVE SO MANY
PEOPLE WHO ARE DEALING WITH
THIS.
>> LOOK, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
PEOPLE WITH LOCO INDIVIDUAL ARE
DEALING WITH RIGHT NOW IS NOT
BEING BELIEVED OR PEOPLE NOT
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THEY'RE GOING
THROUGH.
I REMEMBER TALKING TO SENATOR
TIM KAINE A FEW WEEKS AGO WHO IS
DEALING WITH LONG COVID AND HE
JUST SAID HIS NERVE ENDINGS ARE
ON FIRE HALF THE TIME.
HE WAKES UP AT NIGHT AND HE
FEELS THIS ONGOING TINGLING AND
PAIN.
I DON'T KNOW IF THE RESEARCH IS
KEEPING UP WITH THE CONDITION
THAT MANY PEOPLE ARE DEALING
WITH RIGHT NOW.